okay so last week I told you that
conspiracy theorist mark Dice contacted
me privately via Twitter and he believed
that Wikipedia was out to get
conservatives as evidenced by some
restrictions on changes that can be made
to his page which I later found out is
actually because the page is protected
from vandalism to some degree so anyway
I got a few emails after talking about
this last week pointing out that
absolute and total chaos has broken out
on my Wikipedia page which were linking
to in the description for the YouTube
video and I was looking at this this
morning and indeed there has sort of a
fight has developed on my Wikipedia page
as to where and in what context it's
okay to reference that I am Jewish and I
guess maybe it shouldn't be surprising
that the argument is based around that
I'm gonna show you what's taking place
here these are just a couple of data
points there's almost too many of these
edits that have been done to my page to
even show you the full scope of what's
going on but to set it up for you there
were a bunch of edits made back and
forth back and forth where the first
line of the Wikipedia page about me
refers to me as a Jewish Argentinian
American TV and radio host and then
someone would come in and remove Jewish
and just refer to me as an Argentinean
American television and radio host back
and forth back and forth people adding
that I'm Jewish people taking away that
I'm Jewish from this first line and
eventually someone seemed to have sort
of ended the debate by removing that I'm
Jewish
from that first line and actually
commenting it is not the policy of
Wikipedia to mention celebrities being
Jewish in the headers of Wikipedia
biographies one would not expect to read
Sarah Silverman is a prominent Jewish
comedian in the header of her bio so
that's actually a pretty solid argument
the fact that I'm Jewish was still
mentioned else
we're in the Wikipedia article and it
sort of seemed like things were calming
down
until at some point in the next day or
two someone tries adding to a Jewish
family in the early life section of my
Wikipedia article saying Pakman was born
in Buenos Aires Argentina to a Jewish
family and that seems to be acceptable
by Wikipedia standards and then very
clearly because of the piece that I did
about conspiracy theorists mark dice
complaining to me about his Wikipedia
page why he complained to me as opposed
to anybody else I still haven't figured
out but he did someone added to my
Wikipedia page quote Pakman began
investigating unsolved conspiracies now
he is one of the most prolific
conspiracy theorists on YouTube and as a
reference a link was put in to some
random tweet from I believe years ago on
a day where former producer Lewis went
to Greece on a trip which is a really
weird reference for me being a
conspiracy theorist that was quickly
removed and then things got even weirder
when an edit was made and then undone
and the contents of that edit were
suppressed I've never even seen this
before on Wikipedia a change was made a
revision was made that revision was
reverted in other words the changes were
undone but if you try to look at what
those changes were there's a message
that says you can't view this because
both of these revisions have been
suppressed I don't even know what that
means but I would be very interested in
finding out what on earth was so crazy
or so offensive that was added to my
Wikipedia page that even the record of
it having been temporarily there has to
be suppressed so this entire Wikipedia
thing Pat has really exploded since last
week and if you don't know what I'm
talking about definitely check out the
video about mark dice talking to me
about it we're linking to it on YouTube
but I had no idea that this was going to
become such a big thing yeah before the
biggest tragedy on your Wikipedia page
which was your profile picture that they
had of you now there's certainly a lot
more to complain about and I hope this
does resolve itself because it does look
like you're sort of under attack here
yes absolutely and you know what I am
weighing in on the side of how
prominently should it be mentioned that
I was born to a Jewish family I don't
believe it needs to be part of the
header I am completely in agreement that
in the same way that you wouldn't expect
to see Sarah Silverman is a Jewish
comedian as the first line of her
Wikipedia page I don't think it's
necessary to see David Pakman is a
Jewish TV and radio host on the first
line of my Wikipedia page if you
disagree with me and I imagine that many
many people will many of them trolls let
me know why and we will I'm open to
having my mind changed